this is a web app this is a web app this
thing here also a web app dude why am i
doing this again i built the same app 10
times with 10 different frameworks using
10 different programming languages it
was a horrible experience but i learned
a lot and i figured out which full stack
framework is the greatest of all time
which will be revealed in dramatic
fashion at the end of this video to
maximize the watch time on this journey
you will meet 10 different server side
frameworks like rails django laravel
spring.net next js phoenix rocket gin
vapor and ktor i realize that's 11 but
you don't need to be good at math to be
a programmer this video was insanely
difficult because each one of these
frameworks uses a different programming
language for each one of them we will
look at the overall developer experience
including things like setup routing
database integration and the overall
architecture now before we get started
here's a warning the framework you
choose by the end of this video is going
to dictate your life for the next 10
years as you grow your startup into a
deca unicorn if your startup fails it's
100 because you didn't choose the right
framework reminds me of when my dad made
me choose which of my pet calves to
slaughter with my own hands for my sixth
birthday now before we look at the code
let's first answer the question of what
does a web framework actually do there
are three main things you should know
first they provide an abstraction over
your relational database they typically
have a built-in object relational mapper
that can migrate code from your
preferred programming language into sql
code that can be used by the database
second they provide routing that can map
a url in the browser to code that you
want to run on the server and third they
provide a way to dynamically insert data
from your database directly into html
for the ui together these three elements
make up the model view controller
architecture or mvc which is by far the
most common approach when building a
full stack web app the first framework
we'll look at is ruby on rails made
famous for building some of the biggest
companies in the world like shopify
airbnb and github rails was
revolutionary when it came out because
it dramatically simplified web
development compared to other approaches
of the day it's still very popular in
2022 and is kind of a rebel in the web
development space it has adjacent
libraries like hotwire stimulus and
turbo that take an html centric approach
to building web apps which goes against
the approach you might see in front-end
frameworks like react angular and vue to
get started with rails you'll first need
to have ruby installed then install the
rails gem and run rails new i'm
developing this app on a fresh install
of wm linux and i did run into some
issues with the initial setup these were
errors that could easily be solved with
a google search but the initial setup
was a little more error prone than other
frameworks once you get the project set
up though the rail cli is extremely
powerful not only does it do things like
serve the application with rail server
but it can also generate a ton of code
for you automatically with commands like
scaffold now if we look in the file
explorer you'll notice a bunch of
different folders here and that's
because rails is a battery's included
framework it handles your relational
database testing logging and a bunch of
other stuff it might look pretty
overwhelming at first your main
application code is contained in the app
directory where you'll find folders for
models views and controllers the first
thing we'll look at is routing and the
routes.rb file from this file we can map
urls to actions in a controller
resources create all the routes we would
need for a basic red feature
automatically it's kind of magical but
what it's actually doing is setting up a
mapping between urls in the browser and
controller actions now when the user
visits a url it will trigger one of
these actions on the server that action
might go and retrieve some data from
your database the logic for that data is
contained in the model but before we can
use the data in the database we need to
run a migration which will take the code
in the model and sync it up with the
actual database and all the data is
managed with an object relational mapper
called activerecord and then finally you
have a view which is an
html.erp file erb stands for embedded
ruby and it allows you to render your
data dynamically inside an html file
overall this provides a very nice
separation of concerns and rails is very
opinionated which means you can achieve
a lot of functionality with very little
code the scaffold not only retrieves
items from the database but it also
provides ui to create and update that
data as well but too much magic can also
be a bad thing depending on who you ask
and ruby is not the most popular
language in the world but python is what
if there is a way we could build web
apps like this with python and that's
where django comes in it's also
extremely popular and has been used to
build massive sites like spotify and
bitbucket when you generate a new django
app you'll notice the file structure is
far less overwhelming than rails but at
the same time it's still very much a
battery's included framework in addition
your code tends to be a lot more
explicit for example we have this manage
py file that contains the code for the
actual command line interface to
generate things in the project we could
use it to serve the app locally or
generate an app to represent a feature
of the website it also follows the mvc
architecture with routes being defined
in the urls.py file and controllers are
represented as python functions in the
views.py file a route points to one of
these functions which itself might want
to access data from one of our models a
model is a python class that represents
the structure of data in an sql database
aka the object relational mapper and
finally we have our html templates that
allow you to embed python directly into
the code that's pretty cool but one
extra superpower of django is that it
has an admin feature built into it
directly as you define models in your
application you can register them with
the admin app to easily manage all of
your data in the browser this is really
useful and not something that you'd want
to roll out on your own python's great
null but the original server-side
language of the web was php there have
been countless php frameworks over the
years and high-level tools like
wordpress but the most popular one today
is laravel the php framework for web
artisans to use it you'll first want to
install php and a tool called composer
when i generated my initial app it took
a long time and downloaded a lot of
packages and as you can see the initial
project has a lot of batteries included
even more so than rails if we look at
routes you can see it not only handles
web routes but also api routes and
channels for real-time communication
with websockets now if we go into the
app code you'll notice it's already been
configured with things like user
authentication via providers a provider
is like a shared service that you can
use anywhere in the application in the
http directory we will find our
controllers and just like rails we have
a class that contains a bunch of
different methods that can access data
and render a specific template now our
database models use a tool called
eloquent orm which is based on the same
active record pattern as rails now when
it comes to views php is a language
that's designed to work with html out of
the box larvale makes it even easier by
building on top of php with blade
templates another cool point about the
ecosystem is that they put a lot of
thought into how to integrate front end
frameworks like react and vue it has an
adjacent tool called inertia that can
bridge the gap between front end and
back end frameworks the next framework
we'll look at is next.js which allows us
to build a full stack application
entirely with javascript now in the
javascript world there's a million
different options we could have chosen
here like nuxjs angular universal
sveltkit sjs adonis and many others
maybe i'll make a top 10 video just for
those to get started with next we run
npx create next app and that will
generate a starter project now the one
thing you'll notice about next right off
the bat is that it doesn't provide any
integration for your database there are
a million different solutions to choose
from but one of my personal favorites is
prisma so i'm going to add prisma to
this project the fact that next.js
doesn't have a database out of the box
is a good thing in my opinion the
javascript ecosystem is just way too
crazy it's nice to start with a very
good minimal framework and then add
whatever database integration you want
on top of it now that we have a database
integrated let's take a look at the
pages directory one thing that's
different about next is that routing is
handled with the file system each file
defined in the pages directory defines a
different url in the browser dynamic
routes can be created by wrapping the
file name in brackets now each one of
these files exports a react component to
define the ui or view this is actually
really convenient because many other
frameworks will ultimately want to have
some kind of front-end framework having
react fundamentally integrated into the
framework can streamline your
productivity big time now things get
more complex when you think about data
fetching normally in a react app you're
thinking about client-side code but in
next.js you can also run server-side
code with functions like get server-side
props this function will run on the
server with node.js and as you can see
inside of it we're using prisma to fetch
some items from the database these items
can be delivered as props to the react
component where they're rendered in the
ui both your server side and client-side
code is tightly coupled together which
may feel like a bad separation of
concerns but generally speaking it
actually works very well overall next.js
feels very minimal compared to other
frameworks in this list but it does a
ton of stuff behind the scenes to
simplify the annoying parts of web
development now speaking of simple we're
going to do the polar opposite and see
what java has to offer even though java
is a boilerplate driven language for
writing instant legacy code the spring
framework actually makes it very
enjoyable to work with the first thing
you'll notice when building with it is
that it's kind of like a create your own
adventure story it has a generator that
allows you to start with a framework and
you can even use kotlin or groovy if
you'd like then you choose all the
different dependencies that you want to
add to this project now even though java
does have a lot of boilerplate the code
pretty much writes itself and in my
opinion it feels a lot more robust
compared to the dynamic languages that
we've looked at so far you'll find the
source code way down in this deeply
nested folder and it also follows the
mvc pattern the controller is a class
and a route is defined using a decorator
on each one of its methods spring relies
on a lot of meta programming to keep
your code nice and simple it feels very
much like angular and the javascript
world the database models are based on
code with the java persistence api then
we can use that data in templates using
time leaf where you add these attributes
to your html to define where your data
should go to be honest though i didn't
have a very good time using time leaf
and that brings me to java's arch
nemesis c-sharp and the.net framework or
asp.net it's an open source project
maintained by microsoft and obviously
feels very microsofty but is extremely
popular and reliable it's evolved very
nicely over the years and has modern
supporting libraries like blazer that
allow you to build client-side apps
using webassembly and c-sharp to use it
install the.net sdk then generate a new
mvc application i really like the
initial project structure everything is
clearly named and it's not too
overwhelming and you get all the awesome
tooling and static typing like you do in
java when it comes to routing the urls
are inferred from the class names and
your controllers here we have an animals
controller which gives us the animal's
url then we have methods in that class
that then represent the next url segment
the method can take an argument to
create a dynamic url to represent our
data we have a model that is managed by
an orm called the entity core framework
and then finally we have our views which
are written in cshtml at the top of one
of these files you'll notice a model
where we can access our data and we can
also declare additional data here in c
sharp like a title it's more verbose
than other templating languages but you
get full intellisense inside of it which
is really helpful overall net is really
impressive the only real drawback is
that you have to sell your soul to the
big giant tech corporation if you want
to take the righteous path another
awesome framework to check out is
phoenix which is based on the elixir
programming language it's a functional
language that feels much different than
most of the object-oriented languages
that we've looked at throughout the
video don't worry a 100 second video is
coming soon install it then generate a
new project like ruby on rails it has a
very powerful cli that can automatically
scaffold an entire crud application for
you routing is also very similar to
rails where we have resources that map
all the necessary cred urls to the
controller in the controller we have
functions namespaced under a module that
access data and render the appropriate
template the model uses an object
relational mapper called ecto and
templates use embedded elixir which
again feels very similar to rails
however phoenix has a huge advantage in
performance because elixir is a compiled
language as an added bonus every app has
a built-in live dashboard to closely
monitor performance and that brings us
to another high performance framework
worth checking out jin which is powered
by the go language it easily wins the
best logo award to get started we're not
going to use a fancy cli but instead
create a go project from scratch jin is
a minimal http framework and is not
concerned with the model view controller
architecture we'll have to figure that
out on our own it also doesn't contain
an orm for the database so for that
we'll bring in another package called
gorm the nice thing about this approach
is that we don't really need to follow
the nbc conventions of a framework which
is probably overkill for many
applications instead we can write some
very focused functions and do things in
a way that makes sense for our exact
business needs like in this app we just
have two routes that need to retrieve
some data from a database which itself
is modeled with a struct using the orm
then go has its own built-in templating
language so we can simply create a
couple of template files here in the
project and interpolate the values that
we retrieve from the database the end
result is a much smaller code base with
a lot more low-level control however as
this application grows bigger it's going
to get harder and harder so you really
kind of have to know what you're doing
and that brings us to our next language
rust and the web framework rocket as far
as i know the rust ecosystem doesn't
have a full-blown mvc framework like
rails and to be honest i found it very
difficult to build a basic application
my approach was to use rocket for http
and routing then combine it with diesel
which is a rust-based orm and then
finally a templating language to use the
data in html called ascama i think this
is a reasonable approach but i didn't
quite get to a full working demo with
rust it's a systems language that gives
you low level control over memory which
the average web application developer
doesn't really need i quickly realized
that it would take more time and
dedication than i'm willing to give for
the tail end of a silly youtube video
however there is one rust-based library
that i want to bring to your attention
called you it's a component-based
framework for building web apps with
webassembly and it's coming to a
fireship tutorial near you soon and that
brings us to the final framework in this
list vapor which is based on the swift
programming language this is the only
app that i built on my mac because i
found that anything with swift just
works better on a mac it provides you
with a project structure that looks like
this it's well organized with
controllers models and routes routes
point to methods in the controller which
can access data from a model it uses an
orm called fluent which uses classes
along with decorators to model your data
swift is a very well-designed language
and i found it very enjoyable to work
with for stuff like this the code is
concise and readable yet statically
typed with awesome tooling like you
would get in java or c-sharp i also like
how it embraces async of weight when
fetching data from your models for
templating it has an engine called leaf
which also felt very modern and
practical now that we look at vapor i
want to also mention ktor which is a
kotlin-based web application framework
it's a lot more minimal than something
like spring but also something worth
checking out and with that we've looked
at 10 full stack frameworks now i'm
ready to show you the best full stack
framework in the world you're looking at
your own reflection in the mirror yes it
was you all along without you the
framework would be nothing actually no
no that's that's just dumb ruby on rails
is by far the best framework nothing
else even comes close it's like the
magic jordan of web frameworks thanks
for watching and i will see you in the
next one